So let's do a little example here just to get a feel for
what you can do in continuous output spaces with machine learning.
It's a contrived example, but suppose we graph all the people in the world and
record their age and their net worth.
If you don't know what net worth is, this is kind of the total money that you
kind of own, both in cash, and houses, and cars, and so on.
And just for the sake of the argument,
let me assume there aren't quite seven billion people, and the relationship
between net worth and age looks about like this.
In reality, that's often not the case.
But let's assume that's the case here.
I now want you to fit an imaginary line through the data and
pick two of the points I'm kind of marking here,
as two representative points to which the line would go.
Just click on two of those points that best represent the line,
that best describes the data.